franck mieux que ça
[Musique]
et rangés par ordre chronologique
entre 6h
non un leader aux morts
nous pénétrons maintenant dans les
jardins du palais de versailles le coeur
de la monarchie française
c'est dans le bosquet suivant que
marie-louise de montmorency laval
duchesse de leurs âmes et savourer son
premier chocolat chaud
[Musique]
à ce soir
bon qu'est ce qu'on fait ici nous
déjeunons arrête avec l'humour tu me
fais peur la prof est parti j'ai bossé
comme un cerf hier je veux savoir très
bien nous sommes arrivés trop tôt dans
le futur nous étions censés arriver au
23ème siècle et je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé on est coincé ici pourquoi
le 23ème siècle parce que c'est l'époque
à laquelle appartient la personne qui
nous a contactés tu n'en a aucun
souvenir
mais c'est elle qui t'a rendu visite et
quitta convaincu de faire le voyage
entre lointaine lointaine descendante
plus que la prof donc mais elle est bien
plus évolué que la prof
elle appartient à une époque où les
humains sont capables de voyager dans le
temps
enfin juste pour rendre visite à leurs
ancêtres elle m'a expliqué que suite à
une catastrophe ils ont perdu à peu près
tout ce qui constituait leurs archives
leur mémoire
du coup son organisation les cyber
historiens temps de recréer les traces
de leur passé en recueillant les
témoignages de leurs ancêtres
donc on était censé voyager dans le
futur pour raconter nos mémoires il
devint un des récits passionnants ces
historiens évidemment notre ligne et a
bien perdu de son prestige à ton époque
mais moi moi j'avais tellement de choses
à raconter avant de rentrer chez moi
ce qui n'est plus du tout d'actualité
mais je comprends pas pourquoi notre
cyber historia ne s'est pas contenté
nous poser ces questions chez nous au
lieu de nous faire faire ce voyage qui
est clairement pas au point je vais
poser la question apparemment c'est trop
dangereux pour eux de rester dans le
passé trop longtemps ils ont peur de
modifier leur avenir
une histoire de papillons je soupçonne
qu'elle est voulue m'embrouiller pour
caché qu'en fait ils ne savent pas
maîtriser leur matériel enfin j'ai pas
compris ça tu te faire mal de l'année m
mais j'aurai des curieuses de voir le
23ème siècle
ça doit être encore plus barré que cette
époque j'imagine mais tu aurais rien vu
il t'aurait poser des questions dans une
pièce neutre puis tu aurais ramener chez
toi mais rien ne s'est passé comme prévu
on est coincés ici tu ne te souviens de
rien et moi je veux trouver un moyen de
rentrer chez moi c'est pas moi qui vais
t'aider alors je sais rien et puis je
suis plutôt pas mal ici
pareil j'ai une meilleure espérance de
vie je sais pas ce que je ferais sans
internet maintenant que j'ai goûté geek
je me doutais que tu serais à peu près
aussi utile que d'habitude mais est ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas quelqu'un dans
notre ligne et qui seraient passés par
ici tu m'as parlé d'une révolutionnaire
un jour il n'y a pas quelqu'un parmi
nous qui on s'est davantage
hoyé pas mal de personnes mais c'était
toujours pareil il y apparaissait un
jour disparaissait le lendemain on est
les seuls à être restée à part peut-être
ça va pas de plaire dit toujours une
pirate une pirate
parmi nos descendante la situation ne
peut pas être plus cauchemardesque alors
vas-y continue où se trouvent sept
pirates maintenant aucune idée mais elle
est restée plus longtemps que les autres
le temps de vider les réserves de rome
de la prof en fait et puis elle a
disparu
je sais que la prof la chercher dans des
pme mais elle a fini par laisser tomber
elle est peut-être toujours dans le coin
c'est elle est restée dans cette époque
il faut la trouver
elle en sait peut-être davantage et quoi
qu'il en soit être plus nombreuses nous
rendra plus forte si vis pacem para
bellum
je sens que je vais le regretter il faut
que tu partes à sa recherche mais
pourquoi pas toi ça te ressemble pas je
suis sûr que tu as un truc derrière la
tête mais c'est évident voyons tu
ressemble davantage à la prof et puis tu
connais mieux que moi les us et coutumes
du 21e siècle
tu n'auras qu'à lui prendre quelques
vêtements et tu passeras pour elle sans
problème et puis notre dieu fonctionne
mais aussi de toute manière je dirige et
tu exécutes je superviserai des
opérations depuis ici depuis ton canapé
je suppose super plan si je mourrai pas
envie de sortir d'ici je dirais que
c'est un point à la con tope là très
bien faisons comme ça allons-y et ne
fait pas de bêtise
enfin pas plus que d'habitude je sens
que je ne regrettais
[Musique]